Çok
[Müzik]
teşekkür ederim
Merhaba
bir kere daha merhaba Bu kelimenin
anlamını öğrendikten sonra gördüğüm her
şeye Merhaba diyorum başka bir dilden
geliyor ama anlamı çok güzel Benden size
zarar gelmez zku kuşlara kurtlara
ağaçlara sizde de herkese merhaba
diyorum ve Benden size zarar gelmez
diyerek bu son konuşmacı olmanın da
tabii ki hem alandır hem de ve zaman
tırıyla sohbete başlayalım istiyorum Bu
şekilde ederim
Evet şimdi genellikle beni tanıtırken
Tabii ki öğretmen kimliğim her şeyden
önemli sabah bu Konferansı bir
öğretmenle açtık şimdi bir öğretmenle
kapatalım istiyoruz ama benim için en
önemli şey Sevinç Atabay eşittir öğrenme
öğrenmeden hiçbir şey yapılabileceğine
inanmayan birisiyim ve öğrenmenin o
kadar değerli olduğunu düşünüyorum ki
siz Aman zaman bana sorduklarında seven
çocuğa eğitim sizin için ne demektir
dediklerinde Ben eğitim zihnin
özgürleşmesi dir diyorum Özgür
olabilmemiz için bizim eğitime
ihtiyacımız var Şakran siye cahil Hoca
kitabında çok severim O kitabı bir
Fransız yazar o
bu işte bir benim gibi de biraz aktivist
galiba o yıllarda 1800'lü yıllarda
yaptığı bir yaramazlıktan Belçika'ya
gönderiliyor ve ve şunu yapması
isteniyor
şansızlığı öğretmeni şak rasiye
Belçika'da
bu kansız öğretmesi isteniyor flamanlar
af elemanlar hiç Fransızca bilmiyorlar
şak Raziye de hiçbir zaman ca bilmiyor
ve cahil Hoca bilmediği bir şeyi
bilmeyenlere öğretecek işte orada der ki
bir zihin Özgür Seo zihne hiç kimse
tahakküm edemez özgür bir Zihni hiç
kimse kontrol altına alamaz Onun için
eğitim
zihnin özgürleşmesi dir öğrenin
zihninizi özgürleştir in budu
41'inci Hatta 42 yılında 62 yaşında bir
öğretmen olarak söylüyorum size ama bir
de şunun için söylüyorum Henry Ford'un
çok sevdiğim bir sözü vardır insan
öğrenmeyi bıraktığında asıl yaşlanır der
Ben de öğrenmeye devam edip doğrusu hiç
yaşlanmak istemiyorum onun için tavsiye
ediyorum özellikle de hanımlar ve
başlamak için öğrenmeye devam edin
hayatımı
3 ya da dört bölüme ayırıyorum 41 yıllık
ya da şimdi 42 yılında olan çalışma
hayatımı Bunun adına çıkış diyebiliriz
kapılar diyebiliriz bugünkü bütün
sohbetler üzerinden Tabii ki
konferansımız ın ana konusu olan çıkış
üzerinden Konuşabiliriz ama bir çoğunuz
zaten dünyaya bir çıkışla geliyoruz
dokuz ay bekleyip bir bağırarak
çıkıyoruz ve bütün dünyayı sanki biz
kurtaracağız ve her şeyi biz yapacağız
gibi önemli olan sizinle istediğiniz
işte her birimiz çeşitli konferanslar da
duyarız iç motivasyon dış motivasyon
gibi pek çok şeyler Aslında her şey
sizin içinizde ve sizin zihninizde zihin
o kadar önemli ki bizi kontrol ediyor
her bakımdan kontrol ediyor Bunu bunu
söylerken
şu an o kadar çok yeni mesaj bu durum ki
daha iki gün önce duydum zihin
mühendisleri olmaya başlamış işte
hocamın tayt Aslında dönüşümün mimarı
diye gördüm Çok güzel kendime böyle bir
şey bulsam Acaba ne derdim bilmiyorum
Fakat batth Abi iki bazı kavramları
kullanmak o kadar kolay değil ancak
şakası ile yaptığı gibi hiç bilmeyenlere
bir şey öğretebilmek aslında bu hayatla
ilgili yapmak istedikleriniz konusunda
en önemlisidir bir başka kitapta son
konuşma kitabında
pankreas kanserinden ölmek üzere
olacağını öğrenen çok genç bir profesör
döner Üniversitesi'ne çok da küçük
çocukları vardır Ben kısa bir ömrüm
kaldı ne yapacağım der ve
Üniversitesi'nde bir son konuşma
gerçekleştirir o konuşmada benim için
önemli olan cümle
ve bugüne kadar kendi Hayallerimi
gerçekleştirdim bundan sonra da
Başkalarının hayallerini gerçekleştirmek
istiyorum der ve o son konuşma kitabı
konuşması yıllarca dinlenilir hala daha
Dinleniyor rende boş isminde bir karne
gene lan Üniversitesi'nden Bir
profesörün kitabı şimdi bu 4 bölüm diye
düşündüğümde Aslında İlk başları hep
kendi Hayallerim olmuş Sonuncusu da
başkalarının hayalleri için ben bilerek
ve isteyerek bir öğretmen olarak hayata
başladım İngilizce öğretmen olarak
hayata başladım ancak çok büyük bir
hevesle başladığım bu öğretmenlikte
önüme çıkan yollar kapılar çıkışlar beni
alıp başka yerlere götürdü Ve çok genç
yaşında Amerika'da şu kablodan eğitim
ateşesi oldum öğrenme başladı Ben
İngilizce öğretmeni olduğumu ve
İngilizce bildiğini düşünürken Bir de
baktım ki orada otur Bu
odanın ofisin kirasını yıllarca
ödenmediğini öğrenip Bir de mahkemeye
çıkıp hakimin karşısında söylediklerini
anlamayıp hiçbir cevap veremeyince
İngilizce bilmediğimi gördüm İngilizce
bilmek sadece tahtaya geçip gramerleri
öğretmek olmadığını Tam aksine Söylenen
her şeyi anlamak olduğunu gördüm anlamak
çok önemlidir biliyor musunuz Bugün
hepiniz burada epey bir saattir
buradasınız Ne anladık diye sormak lazım
birbirimize o diyorlar ya seçici algıyla
dinleyin dinlemek çok önemlidir bizim
ülkemizin en önemli sorunu dinlemektir
Çünkü herkes dinlediğini zanneder Oysa
karşısındakine vereceği cevabı düşünür
kafasından dinlemediğimiz de anlamayız
ya o yüzden hep dinlemeyi çok önemli
bulurum konuşmaktan daha önemlidir
dinlemek ve anladım ki ben dinlediğimi
anlamadım orada duyduklarımı anlamadım
Daha önemlisi ve yeniden bir okula
başladım öğrenmem gerekti Bu benim için
bir deneyimdi ardından uzun bir zaman
tabi ülke temsiliyeti bir tarafa
Bırakıyorum tekrar Türkiye'de başka
görevler sonra yeni bir dönem başladı
Benim için altı sene Avrupa'nın çeşitli
ülkelerinden olan benim gibi çalışan
devlet memurları ile ama başka Başka
ülkelerden olan devlet memurları ile
birlikte altı yıl bir Avrupa Birliği
süreci yaşadım o bambaşka bir deneyimdi
o bana çok şey öğretti ne öğretti
biliyor musunuz diploması dilinde hayır
demenin Evet olduğunu evet demeden Hayır
olduğunu ya da hiç cevap vermemenin Çok
şey söylemek olduğunu gösterdi ve
anladım ki dış politika dönem böyle bir
durum söz konusu Orada öğren da buydu
Tabii ki şu anda kendimi evimde gibi
hissettiğim bir TED Okulu'nda olmak test
Sivas Koleji'nde olmak Benim 16 yıllık
TED okulları ile olan beraberliğini çok
önemli bir duygusal da anı bugün burada
olmak o da bana öğrencilerle ve
velilerle
Öğretmenlerle çok daha yakın birlikte
olma sürecinde nelerin önemli olduğunu
gördü ki bu nedenle ben çok sevgili
öğretmenlerim ederim ki bir şey
öğretmeye kalkmayın
öğrencilerimizden öğrenme merakını
yaratın öğrenme hevesini yaratın bir
insan öğrenme hevesiyle başlarsa
dünyalar Onun önünde duramaz O yüzden
öğretmenler öğretmeyin heves yaratın
merak öğrenme merakla başlar işte Az
önce sevgili bir yanından dinledik üç
tane çocuk Küçücük küçücük Şimdi onların
her şeye merakla bakışı bu ne bu ne bu
ne bu ne diye sorması Biliyor musunuz
Bir Çocuk konuşmaya başladı o
ilk soruları bu ne diye başlar ve biz
iki buçuk üç yaşında konuşmaya başlayan
o çocuklar her şeyi sorgularken nasıl
oluyor da
bu yaş ilerledikçe Hele bu yaşlara
geldikçe sorgulamayı unutuyoruz sormayı
unutuyoruz anlamıyorum doğrusu nasıl
yapıyoruz bu hatayı bilmiyorum Size bu
vesileyle söylemek istediğim diğer bir
hususta lütfen
kendinize Etrafınıza olaylara ülkemize
ve dünyaya soru sorarak bakın
sorgulamak çok önemlidir hiçbir şey tek
başına doğru değil ya da yanlış değildir
ama sorgulamak Onun ne olduğunu öğrenmek
en önemlisidir Hele ki işte Mustafa Bey
bugün bize dijital dönüşümü anlattı
böyle bir bilginin kolay eleştire
bildiği bir yüzyılda öğrenmek için
duyduklarınız
arkadaşlarımız sohbetler sırasında ki
değil gerçek bilgiye ulaşmak için çaba
gösterin
manikürün çok sevdiğim bir sözü vardır
Marie o
zaman zaman bana sorarlar Sevinç Hanım
sizin rol model lerinizi şey sevdiğiniz
kitap kim rol model oldu buna şöyle
cevap veririm bizi seminerle bir kitapla
Hayat değişmez çok seminerle çok kitapla
Hayat Değişir bir kişiyi tanımakla Hayat
değişmez çok kişi tanımakla değişir
bugün burada 8 değerli konuşmacı
dinledik eminim hepiniz buradan
ayrılırken Onların her birinden
etkilendiğiniz ve bir şey öğrendiniz
bununla hayatınız başka olacak Bu arada
süreyi görmüyorum 18 dakika Ne olacak
bilmiyorum hiçbir şekilde süreyi
görmüyorum haber vereyim En azından bana
Zile uyarı yapabilirsiniz kaç dakikam
var ona en azından bir değil
Dolayısıyla
manikürü der ki gördüğüm ve öğrendiğim
her şey beni o kadar mutlu ediyordu ki
yeni bir dünyayı keşfetmiş gibi ol abi
bilimle bu keşfi yapmak beni başka
dünyalara götürüyordu Siz de öyle bakın
öğrenmenin bu etkisini asla ve asla
Unutmayın sonra ikinci kapıdan sonra ve
tende olan benim bu uzun yolculuğundan
sonra emeklilik kararını alıp
yeni bir kapı yeni bir çıkış ne
yapacaktım ne yapmayacağımı biliyordum
aslında
az önce yine benzinde söylediği gibi
takvimler saatler yetiştirecek hiçbir
şey olsun istemiyordum daha çok
öğrenebileceğim başka bilmediğim
alanları keşfedebilir ceğim yollara
çıkmak istiyordum ki yaz tatili idi Ve
benim bulunduğum yerde yangınlar
başlamıştı bugüne kadar pek çok Sivil
toplum kuruluşunda çalıştım çünkü sivil
toplum kuruluşlarının yapmak istedikleri
hem devletin yapamadıkları konusunda hem
de iyi bir insan olarak sorumluluk
duymak o sorumlulukla Kendi ülkesine
başka ülkelere insanlara hayvanlara
doğaya destek olmak çok değerlidir diye
Bakalım o yüzden çok fazla Selim toplum
kuruluşunda çalışma yaparım o çalıştığım
sivil toplum kuruluşları bana telefon
etmeye başladılar seven çocuğun
yangınlar başladı hepimiz koşuyoruz
gidiyoruz destek oluyoruz ama başka ne
yapabiliriz onlar için dediklerinde
Tabii ki eğitimci kimliği ve artık daha
da fazla zamanım olacağı için Onlara
dedim ki biliyor musunuz artık dünyanın
yepyeni bir sorunu var iklim krizi
Elbette ki bu yangınlarla ilgili bize
pek çok şey söyleniyor
Sabotaj olabilir kastı olabilir ama bir
de iklim krizi gibi bir gerçek var bakın
Bugün instagramımda bir fotoğrafı
paylaştım İsviçre'de dünya ekonomik
forumu başlıyor ve o Forum'a giden
bu
sermaye Dünyası özel jetlerle gidiyorlar
ne konuşacaklar biliyor musunuz Karbon
ayak izinin sorunu nasıl çözebiliriz
diye
Ojelerin çıkarttığı karbon herkesin ne
olduğunu biliyorsunuz değil mi şekle
gidip bunu konuşmak işte böyle bir
dünyada yaşarken bizlerin sorgulayan
öğrenen merakla ve bir sorunu çözmek
isteyerek yaklaşımı bu sorunları çözecek
özellikle Burada bulunan Ben gençlere
seslenmek istiyorum
farkında olmanız gerekiyor Dolayısıyla o
gün başladım ve ben bir program yaptım
bütün yanan köyleri dolaşarak benimle
birlikte Buna destek olmak isteyen
öğretmen Arkadaşlarımla birlikte köyleri
dolaşıp annelere ve çocuklara özellikle
iklim değişikliğinin iklim krizinin ne
olduğunu dahası iklim adaletinin ne
olduğunu anlatmaya çalıştım iklim da
aletsiz biliyor musunuz hiç iklim
krizine neden olmayan asla Sanayi ile
ilgilenmeyen karbon üretmeyen ülkeler
Afrika ülkelerinin insanları iklim
krizinden en çok etkilenecek olanlar
Önümüzdeki on yıl içinde Milyonlarca
İnsan vatanını toprağını köyünü şehrini
terk etmek zorunda kalacak bizim
hepimizin bunu anlatması gerekiyor ve
şunu gördüm ki artık bu küresel
dediğimiz mesele sorunlarda küresel
bakın bir virüs geldi bütün dünyayı
etkiledi ve sorun küreselde çözümü de
küresel olduğu bir aşı üretildi Bu
nedenle yine sevgili gençler ediyorum ki
küresel sorunlara küresel çözümler
üretmek üzere beyninizi kullanın
artık fikirlerde küresel olacak
yazılarda küresel olacak konuş ve
küresel olacak Dolayısıyla bu süreci
mide artık böyle çalışmalarla yapıyorum
ve bütün bunları
sohbetlerde daha nasıl kısaltır ve
hepimizin zihnini ortak hale
getirebilirim dediğimde yedi tane kelime
üzerinden artık uygulamaya başladım ilk
kelimem farkındalık her şeyin farkında
olan olur mu etrafınız ın olup bitenin
Ama en çok da kendinizin farkında olun
kendinizle tanışın
uzaklaşmayın en büyük hatamız dır
kendimizden uzaklaşmak önce kendinizi
farkedin sonra etrafınızı farkedin
farkındalık en önemli şeydir ikinci
kelimem etki
yaptığınız Her işte ben nasıl bir değer
üretiyorum diye bakın etki yaratmadığını
hiçbir şeyin değeri yoktur nice der ki
Zaman zaman sakin kalın oturun zihninizi
temizleyin Bu bir baca temizliği ile
benzetir bacağınızı temizleyin ve ben
sırtımda değer üretmeyen hiçbir şey
taşımak istemiyorum değil ve yaptığınız
her işte bir etki yaratmaya çalışın 3.
kelimem Çevik olun hocam bahsetti ama
Çelikli Ben de şöyle tanımıyorum öyle
Çevik olun zihninizi öyle ya kullanın ki
ne yapacağınızı bilmediğiniz durumlarda
ne yapabilirsiniz kendinize onu hazır
edin onun için de çok öğrenmeniz
gerekiyor sakın öğrenmeyi bırakmayın
dördüncü kelimem
yılmazlık
yılmazlık kelimesinin anlatımı çok uzun
ama kısacık söylersem yılmayın var olan
herşeyi elinizde tutmaya çalışın onu
olduğu gibi koruyun Burada da Atatürk'ün
çok güzel bir sözü var derki hayatımın
hiçbir döneminde karamsar olmadım
önümdeki engelleri tek tek kaldırdım
yılmayın de devam edin V kelimem
bağışıklık en çok da gitti öğrendik hem
ruhsal hem fiziksel
bağışıklığınızı sakın ihmal etmeyin
sadece vitaminler alarak bedeninizin
bağışıklığını Koru mayın Buranın da
bağışıklığı her şeyden önemli ruhunuz
bağışıklığı Eğer bedelini zaten bağışık
oluyor altıncı kelimem
sürdürülebilirlik en önemli kelime
Ben Altmış iki yaşında
karşınızda yeni bir şey
söyleyebiliyorsan kendimi Sürdürülebilir
olduğu için kişisel gelişiminizi
sağlığınızı
Bilgilerinizi hep yenileyin ve
Sürdürülebilir olun Tabii ki dünyanın
Sürdürülebilir olması her şeyden önemli
sonuna mı geldik son kelimem gönüllülük
Ben bir gönüllüyüm ülkem için gönüllüyüm
bu topraklar Bu bayrak için gönüllüyüm
her şeyde gönüllü olun Bütün sorunları
çözmekte Elbette başarılı olabiliriz ama
Gönlümüz Bu çalışmak gönüllü destek
olmak hepsinden önemlidir hepinize
teşekkür ediyor Sevgilerimi sunuyorum
Sağ olun sağ olun Çok teşekkürler